ce rassemblement maintenant en soutien à
julian assange organisé aujourd'hui à
bruxelles
une journée dédiée à la liberté
d'expression et d'information de soutien
donc aux lanceurs d'alerté actuellement
emprisonné à londres julian assange qui
on le rappelle avait en 2010 révélée via
wikileaks de nombreux documents mettant
en cause l'armée américaine à bruxelles
les précisions de notre reporter et
stéphane honoré a les héros de la vie
numérique que ce sont là les mots de
edwy plenel le fondateur de mediapart
est des mots à qui résume l'objectif de
cette journée dédiée à julian assange et
au lanceur d'alert comme chelsea manning
edouard de snowdon ou encore sarah
harrison une cérémonie à qui vient tout
juste de se terminer et est organisée
ici au palais à des académies de
bruxelles à cérémonie à l'initiative de
cartes à académica une association qui
regroupe des universitaires engagés
cérémonie pour rappeler l'importance du
droit de savoir je vous propose
d'écouter à ce propos edwy plenel le
fondateur de mediapart
ça traduit là le cours que nous avons
sous nos yeux de pouvoir autoritaire
issue de l'élection
nous ne sommes pas dans un temps de
dictature nous avons des pouvoirs qui
ont le visage de monsieur poutine de
monsieur macron de monsieur train de
monsieur erdogan de monsieur et daublain
d'autres qui sortent des urnes et qui
considèrent que la légitimité des urnes
suffit comme seule légitimité que ils
confisquent la souveraineté populaire
parce qu'ils ont été élus eh bien non la
souveraineté populaire elle passe par
une complexité la démocratie un éco
système démocratique où il y a à la fois
le droit de vote
au final mais avant cela il y a la
possibilité de s'exprimer
la possibilité de s'informer la
possibilité de dévoiler des mensonges de
dévoiler des impostures la possibilité
de protester de manifester librement
pacifiquement
et donc le sort de assange le sort de
celle ci manning le sort des douars
zenden le sort de glenn greenwald le
sort de rio tinto
qu'est ce que c'est ils ont révélé des
crimes de guerre ils ont révélé des
surveillances de masse ils ont révélé
des fraudes des fraudes fiscales ils ont
révélé des corruptions des corruptions
économique et financière ils ont révélé
des mensonges d'état des crimes d'état
tout cela au nom de l'intérêt public ils
ont servi le bien commun ce sont des
héros d'un combat fondamental pour la
vitalité de la démocratie face à la
tendance dans notre époque de cours
autoritaire y compris de pouvoir
apparemment démocratique
voilà sans joie des uns comme on le
nomme ici va se poursuivre à présent
place de la monnaie là bas une oeuvre de
l'artiste italien davide dormino sera
inauguré il s'agit en réalité de trois
statues de bronze représentant les
lanceurs d'alerté dont que julian
assange
edward e snowdon et celle ci à manning
des statuts qui resteront exposées ici à
bruxelles pendant trois jours voilà pour
cette journée à de soutien à julian
assange qui intervient un mois avant
l'ouverture du procès à londres du
lanceur d alerte
assange qui a je le rappelle risque 175
ans de prison et une extradition vers
les etats-unis